dubai isn't your average cosmopolitan
city
it's a lively place rich in culture and
steeped in history
and although it may be known for
architectural marvels
the city is complemented by an array of
landscapes
wildlife and natural wonders what sets
it apart
is its many unexpected surprises
the first location gives us a glimpse
into the city's history and beginnings
as a thriving trade hub
set in the spectacular desert landscape
the saruk al-hadid archaeological site
is one of the most exciting discoveries
of the 21st century
the site is considered to have been a
center of constant human habitation
trade and metallurgy dating back over
three thousand years to the iron age
unique artifacts discovered at the site
are on public display
at the world's only live museum the
soruk al-hadid archaeology museum allows
visitors to delve deeper into the story
of bustling
trade routes between some of the most
influential civilizations
regularly updated artifacts housed at
the museum include axe heads and daggers
to metal and stone jewelry
among them a 4 000 year old intricate
gold ring which inspired the logo of the
iconic expo 2020
the 3d cinematic room transports
visitors to the edge of the desert to
learn more about some of the fascinating
discoveries
our next spot is home to a huge variety
of feathered residents
[Music]
just inside the bustling city of dubai
you'll find a treasure trove of diverse
bird life
in the vast wetlands of the russell
corps wildlife sanctuary
known as the cape of the creek it
comprises a variety of salt flats
mangroves and natural lagoons that is
one of the few urban protected areas in
the region
from one of the three bird hides you can
witness more than 25
000 resident and migratory birds which
include
great egrets reef herons cormorants and
more
though the real stars of the show are
the pink flamingos that flock to the
area during the winter
in the hope of attracting a mate a leica
telescope sits at the mangrove hide on
the southern edge of the sanctuary
to watch the majestic raptors and
greater spotted eagles
soar overhead guided tours take visitors
on a journey to explore the wetlands
through the eyes of a conservationist
[Music]
our next location goes deep into the
water off dubai's coast
a short ride from dubai's glistening
shoreline lies a little-known
marine adventure the emerald waters of
the gulf were once known for pearl
diving
and bustling trade over 500 species of
aquatic life reside in the pristine
warm waters surrounding dubai these
waters are home to many
magical secrets of the underwater world
one of the most popular dive sites sits
at a depth of 30 meters
the zaynab a 70 meter long oil smuggling
vessel
bound for asia is a thrilling deep wreck
site for advanced
open water divers other interesting
wrecks include the sheikh mohammed barge
neptune 6 and victoria star where divers
can explore
many more mysteries that lie deep below
next we head into the desert to discover
diverse wildlife that thrives in one of
the largest conservation reserves in the
region
only half an hour from dubai and
spanning more than 40 hectares of
tranquil desert shrubland and wetlands
the el mar moon reserve is home to over
200 species of native birds
the name marmom is inspired by one of
its most revered occupants the hubara
bustard
an internationally protected species of
bird that nomadic civilizations relied
on heavily to survive in the arabian
deserts
tall observation towers like the nest
look out over 19 species of endangered
animals
the highest concentration of large
flamingos in a desert environment and
one of the largest arabian gazelle herds
in the uae
the almar moon bedouin experience takes
visitors on a historical adventure
to discover what life was like in the
9th century when nomadic bedouin
traversed the deserts
visitors can enjoy cultural performances
a falcon show
and delectable emirati cuisine
surrounded by the majesty
of the desert dunes
and last we travel through the desert in
the dark of the night
to experience the wonders of islamic
astronomy
[Music]
thousands of years ago to navigate the
vast dunes of dubai
bedouins used a technique involving the
sun and stars
instead of compasses they used their own
shadows as well as sand dunes that were
shaped by the wind to traverse the
desert
due to the constantly shifting landscape
the majority of their traveling was done
by night
when stars lit up the sky making it a
more trustworthy navigation source
the role of islamic astronomy
particularly from the 9th to 13th
centuries
still impacts modern navigation today
these ancient techniques and stories are
still shared in dubai
from the mountains of hatta to the dunes
of almar moon
the mesmerizing tales of the dancer a
ruckus
and the flying eagle altai air are but
just a few
settle in and let these legends
transport you
you